in the belarus capital minsk dozens of
women have been arrested at a protest
against authoritarian president
alexander lukashenko
many of the women were forced into
unmarked vans or
beaten by masked security officials
belarus has been swept by daily
anti-government protests
since last month's disputed presidential
election
it's an unprecedented challenge to
lukashenko who's been in power
for 26 years
a fresh show of determination and
defiance
thousands of women braved heavy security
and an official warning
to raise their voices against the
government once more
demanding that president lukashenka step
down
and that jailed opposition figures be
freed
after more than a month of protests this
rally is just the latest evidence
that belarusians are not going to accept
lukashenka's rule
i don't even know how many times i've
been out here you just can't sit back
and watch what's going on
if you don't come out today tomorrow
your children will live as slaves
and i'm a mother i have children
but as with previous demonstrations this
one took a violent turn
shortly after the rally began scuffles
broke out between protesters and riot
police in the capitals
freedom square masked men could be seen
aggressively confronting demonstrators
ultimately making dozens of arrests
they're grabbing everyone in sight do
they think they can lock up everybody
president lukashenka
says he has no intention of stepping
down he's denied allegations of fraud
in an election that saw him win 80
percent of the vote
but are planning to keep up the pressure
on the president
on sunday tens of thousands of
anti-government protesters
are expected to flood the streets of
minsk once more
and standing by for us in minsk is dw's
nick connolly hello
to you nick so we saw there more arrests
more violence this time targeting women
who were demonstrating
what's been the reaction in minsk to
yesterday's events
well definitely anger if little shock i
think this had been factored in
in recent days we'd seen the police
getting more aggressive and using more
violent tactics towards women after a
period
where as you might remember there had
been slightly
lighter touch towards female protesters
we'd seen
protests where women would stand in
front of men who are protesting or
journalists who are said to be arrested
and
preventing their arrest by standing
between them and the police that is now
definitely over
but interestingly enough those those
arrests came right at the beginning and
after that
after about five minutes of shock and
confusion people
the women out demonstrating did manage
to get regroup and
spent the next two hours protesting
walking through most of the city centre
getting their message and getting a
whole lot of support from people on the
streets clapping them
beeping their horns i think the example
of maria kalesnikova who was abducted
here in minsk last week and who
successfully resisted the attempt by
authorities to throw her out of her own
country by ripping her passport jumping
out of a car window that has definitely
galvanized many here in minsk but nick
where does where do things go from here
i mean lukashenko is still refusing
to meet with the opposition how does the
opposition intend to proceed
that's uh the million-dollar question i
think there's no clear answer to that
this is
unknown territory for a country which
basically for quarter century had no
politics
in which one man called all the big
shots i think this is a kind of cultural
protest now where protests spread beyond
the city streets beyond the sunday
demonstrations i was
in a residential district of minsk just
yesterday evening
in a yard building residential building
where there's been a mural
of some djs who basically came up with
the soundtrack to these protests
that mural has been painted over time
and time again by the authorities here
and time and time again the people
living there
have replaced the mural so that now the
police is there 24 hours a day
essentially guarding a wall to prevent
people from replacing a mural
and the the people who live in that yard
are out talking to the police meeting
every evening drinking tea
there was even an impromptu concert so
there's a level to which the more the
government clamps down the more they're
actually forcing people
closer to one another bringing them
closer and actually encouraging to come
out to protest just out of
out of a spirit of resistance to these
attempts to really clamp down on their
everyday life and their surroundings
well more protests are planned for today
so did yesterday's violence then not
intimidate people are we expecting
a large turnout today
well definitely that arrest of marijuana
her disappearance rather last week is
definitely
uh something that has angered and
shocked many who thought they'd seen
everything here so these streets where
i'm saying now look set to be
a host to tens if not hundreds of
thousands of people later today
um we've seen further warnings from the
government basically trying to
make people think again about coming out
reminding people that any
uh participation in this kind of
demonstration is illegal and will have
consequences for them
so far we've seen those threats aren't
working all right dw's mcconnelly
reporting for us from minsk thank you